that was impressive if you're a Spurs
fan an NBA fan maybe a little alarming
if you're a Suns fan I don't know where
you stand on that but victor wanyama
goes for 20 in the first half another 18
after halftime his 38 points is eclipsed
among Spurs rookies only by David
Robinson in franchise history in terms
of single game scoring he goes 15 of 26
for 38 point w rookie boards it's his
fifth NBA game right maybe more
impressive to me after the Spurs LED
this game by 27 the Suns chipped away
we're sitting here like a lot of you at
home thinking okay Phoenix is coming
back de Booker's going nuts they're
probably going to win this game they
come all the way back to tight at 116
never LED though because the Spurs
finish on a 16 to5 run to close it out
yeah impressive and you were talking
about this pregame about how good he's
been in the fourth quarter and he he was
really good in the fourth quarter again
I mean hit some huge shots for them uh
came up with some big time rebounds just
an incredible Talent uh and as
impressive as this win was for him and
the Spurs to me this is more about the
issues with the Suns and we CH I just
looking at they only got up 79 shots in
this game not very many San Antonio took
98 yeah San Antonio only only had eight
turnovers yeah so there's some real
concern from a defensive standpoint and
where else even when you get Bradley
Beal you've got to have better
basketball play from The Supporting Cast
it's not about just scoring but you got
to have guys that are really good in the
roles you need to be filled if you
really want to be a contender if the
pace that they play at is not conducive
when you have three 30-point scores
right they have to push the ball but you
also have to get stops right it it's the
lineups that they were playing you could
tell they're missing length and we
talked about this before they're missing
there's not a lot of them but this is
why they are valued somebody who 611 7ot
defensive minded who says let me we can
switch one through five I have length I
can protect the rim and I can also make
the guard work the the Spurs were back
cutting the Suns extra effort they were
not no one on the Spurs including weay
Yama is a oneon-one guy none of them so
they win by playing better team
basketball in tonight they were just
chopping the Suns up they picked that
who they want to go to they're running I
was laughing with you they're running
Dallas Mavericks play that they used to
run with Dirk in crunch time for a
19-year-old yeah right they're running
back back door cuts on a timeout which
is a easy bump and switch right if
you're a small guy it's a bump and
rotate out I remember this from five
years ago but the communication is not
there so I'm not saying we're five games
in and obviously I'm pretty hyped up
because watching that kid play and
watching this is interesting but this
film should be a big wakeup call for the
Suns that people are gunning for them
but they also need to get their is with
pressure and a sense of urgency their
chemistry right on the court there's a
lot of new guys they need to figure out
what their lineups are and what they're
missing because I think they have the
talent they just don't play fast enough
and I don't think they're connected
enough right now you know as impressive
is everything that he did tonight was
for Victor wanyama what stands out for
me is the way he accepted the
responsibility of buckets late in the
game when the Spurs are being challenged
by the Suns like he's a veteran like
he's Kevin Durant on the other side I
mean he was looking for his shot he's
taking big shots making big shots like
he's done it a million times before and
that's a great point and again I think
that does speak to the fact that he's
played professional basketball yeah
obviously this is a different level uh
but there is a comfort and a familiarity
when you're used to the physicality uh
and he also knows who he is right like
you didn't see him taking ill-advised
shots or trying to do things he's not
good at he understands why he's regarded
so highly right you know he's a guy
that's going to be a rim deterrent at
the in the paint he's also going to be a
guy that can run the floor make good
decisions when you put the ball in his
hands and he can make shots he's a guy
that can be a knockdown shooter and the
other thing and and this is what Chan
talking about he's also a good
basketball player meaning he can play
without the basketball you know
understands how to utilize Cuts how to
come off of screens and look at that
that's a big time play there gave it up
and went right to the rim there is no
defense for that no you know this guy's
got an incredible feel it's still
mindboggling that he is only 19 years
old because he really has the complete
package that that that's not even fair
that should be illegal they have to
change the rule with that one
conditioning is also because you saw him
run the court like that in the first
half you saw him run like that in the
second half he's being physical
offensive rebounds moving his feet
communicating we're five games into a
season and he's already being asked to
do all this on both ends and he's not
you don't really see him with his hands
on his knees he's still locked in
mentally so his preparedness you got to
give a lot of credit to the Spurs for
putting him in all those situations
early and conditioning him so that he
can make these plays conditioning is not
a factor for him especially for somebody
that's that lanky usually you're like
man you're getting bodied up that's what
we thought but they bodied him up today
and he said no no I'm used to this homie
yeah and it's hard to body him because
he's not just running to the block right
you know and because you generally
you're going to have to put someone with
size on him and when he you know the
further you get away from the basket the
less physical you can be and so when
you're putting a 610 611 guy on him and
he's 25 ft from the the basket and he's
putting you in a picking rooll that
ain't it it it it's really hard and it
also it it inverts your defense meaning
now your bigs are 30 ft from the basket
so you have no Rim protection and
they're going to be cutting right and so
you can't load to them and give pop a
lot of credit for this offense and how
they are able to utilize him because his
skill set is such that man he can play
in all the scoring spots on the floor
very few guys in our league can do that
right now yeah and he's doing it at 19
yeah it's uh it's extraordinary
everything about him the way he moves
his skill level I don't know if you
weren't watching this game if you
haven't seen him play yet Victor wanyama
is taking technical free throws for the
San Antonio Spurs as a rookie at 74
unreal yeah listen just haven't seen
anything like it the alien all